there's one guy in russia that vladimir
putin the president
fears more than anyone else
[Music]
he wears a lot of different hats he's a
political activist he's a youtuber
he's kind of an internet troll he's a
lover of quality drone footage
to help expose corruption which like
come on who doesn't love a good drone
shot
but his main objective is singular it's
very focused
it's to give the russian people and all
of us around the world a peek
behind the curtain to show how russia
really works
exposing the web of bribes corruption
lies
and powerful men who really control
modern russia
this important figure who is seeking to
dismantle russia's web of corruption is
named
alexei navalny and just last week he was
sentenced to three years in jail
as well as being nominated for a nobel
peace prize
after being secretly poisoned on an
airplane
the movement that he has created strikes
at the heart of vladimir putin's biggest
fears
and i want to show you why so let me
introduce you to the man
putin fears the most alexander alexey
alexia alexander russian opposition
leader
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so let's rewind to summer of last
year
alexia navalny is in a city in eastern
russia he's in a hotel room
about to head to the airport to catch a
flight when he arrives to the airport
other passengers recognize him because
he's kind of a big deal in russia and
they snap some photos with him then he
gets on the flight
the flight takes off it's a four-hour
flight from this city of tomsk to moscow
where he's going
everything's going normal for the first
30 minutes of this flight but then
navalny starts to feel weird a flight
attendant offers him a bottle of water
and he refuses
but soon this feeling weird turns into
severe pain
[Music]
he runs to the lavatory looking for some
reprieve he's going in and out of
consciousness
he may be going into a seizure his heart
is slowing down
his muscles are convulsing and seizing
no one has any idea what's happening a
nurse aboard
steps up and helps keep him conscious
while the pilots reroute for an
emergency landing at a nearby city
in russia the plane lands at the closest
airport where medics sprint onto the
runway to help only for the medics to
say
and i quote this is not a case for us he
needs intensive care navalny is then
rushed to a hospital but what happens
inside this hospital
is kind of mind-blowing when he gets to
the hospital
they start running tests on them to see
what's going on but when the doctors
come looking for the results of these
blood tests
the lab technician hands them a blood
test that says that alexis navalny is
totally fine
nothing out of the ordinary maybe a
little bit of irritable bowel issues
but that's not what the doctor has seen
this man looks like he has been
poisoned but the lab technician didn't
hand over any results that indicate that
he was poisoned
something is up the doctors go ahead and
go with their instincts and treat him
for poisoning because that is the
symptoms that they are seeing
they put him on a ventilator and they
put him into a medically induced
coma to recover over the next few days
alexia navalny is in the intensive care
unit
in a coma in this hospital but the
hospital starts to fill up not just with
doctors but
russian government officials who start
barring people like his wife
and his personal doctor from entering
the room navalny
and his family do not feel safe in this
hospital it's at this time that a german
humanitarian non-profit organization
offers to
charter a jet to fly him from this town
in russia
out of russia to be treated in berlin
soon he's on an airplane to berlin where
he arrives at a hospital
and they run all of the same poison
blood tests that they did in russia
but this time they find that he was
poisoned
this would have come up on the test they
did in russia but somebody decided
not to reveal that to the doctors mr
navalny remains in an induced coma
at a berlin hospital the german doctors
are seeing that the poison that was
somehow administered to alexia navalny
is some crazy nerve poison that sends
the victim into a state of paralysis
and gives nerve damage and inducing
seizures
and making their heart slow down it's a
poison that was developed by soviet
scientists during the cold war
and they used it to quietly attack
people they wanted to get rid of like
spies or double agents
it's called novichok and it is a brutal
poison and it was the poison that was
used on alexia navalny
tonight this incredible story the most
prominent russian opposition leader
is in a coma on a ventilator now there's
a lot of ways to poison someone
you can use ingredients that anyone has
access to
novichok is something that is developed
and used only by the russian military
and intelligence
in a sense it's a signature so navalny
goes back into a medically induced coma
in this hospital in berlin where doctors
are doing their best to treat him
and also investigate what happened soon
the world would know exactly what
happened
okay let's just pause for a second while
alexia navalny is in a coma in berlin
because we need to ask an important
question
which is who is this guy and why on
earth is soviet nerve poison being used
against him
for most of his adult life alexia
navalny has been dedicated to one thing
which is shining a light on how russia
really works behind the scenes
not this or this but how it
really works one thing you need to know
about russia
is that the whole society the government
the business structures
everything is built on a giant house of
cards let's say
it's delicate it's fragile but it's the
status quo
and putin is at the top from there you
have the people closest to putin's the
ones that have his ear
they're rich russian billionaires who
control russia's main industries like
oil
and gas mining telecoms all the richest
guys
in russia these guys do favors for putin
and putin
does favors for them in the political
sphere they scratch each other's back
and in doing so they maintain control
over everything that gets done in russia
and this
model repeats itself as it trickles down
to regional governments and then to town
and city governments
who all operate in the same manner
keeping the society stable
through a culture of bribery secrecy and
intimidation and it all happens in the
name of keeping putin
secure in his position so that he can in
turn keep his rich friends happy
the reason why putin fears alexei
navalny
is because navalny wants all russians to
see
exactly how this works to shine a light
on it
which could easily turn the people
against the system
to knock down this house of cards from
the ground
up to stop putting up with a government
that works for the rich corporate owners
and not for the people and if this
happens it's vladimir putin
who has the longest hardest fall okay
but here's the juiciest part of the
story and the part that
got me into this and that i love which
is that the tactics
navalny uses to do this shine a light on
the system thing there's no better way
to describe it than saying he's full on
trolling vladimir putin and his friends
he does this in a lot of ways but what i
love the most are his well-produced
internet explainer documentaries
he makes these long videos exposing the
indulgent corruption of russian
billionaires who control the country
and he uses these visual investigation
techniques that are really
stunning to look at and really
convincing but there's also a good
amount of snarky poking fun in every one
of these videos
like this deep dive into the corruption
of this russian politician that starts
with this goofy iphone video of him
awkwardly dancing at like a wedding or
something
but it's not just all poking fun these
videos then go very deep
and they reveal really useful and
compelling evidence
that shows just how bad this situation
is just how in bed the government
is with these rich billionaires but
always peppered
with a good amount of this
[Music]
he's like a viral internet sensation
meets like
hardcore journalist activist video
vlogger guy
i just he's like just an interesting
character so what is navalny he's kind
of a politician
but he's more than that his specific
policy agenda has morphed and it's
honestly like not that
noble like he totally supported the
annexation of crimea which is like
totally off limits and a terrible thing
that happened and his electability as a
leader isn't very likely
but that's not really at the heart of
his mission his mission isn't about
being elected it's about
dismantling the current system not to
convince people to vote for him
but simply get people to vote against
putin and the status quo
and here's why this scares the [ __ ] out
of vladimir putin
back to our house of cards even though
putin is at the top
of this pyramid it doesn't mean he's all
powerful
he's not like a standard totalitarian
dictator who just has
everyone under his thumb he's only
powerful because he's in the good graces
of
all these super rich guys that own the
massive companies
of gas telecoms mining and natural
resources in russia if these guys turn
on him
he's over putin while powerful is simply
one cog in the machine of keeping these
guys powerful
and immune from laws and regulation
putin isn't afraid that
all these youtube videos are going to
create legal issues
for putin and his friends the courts in
russia are just as influenced by this
culture of bribery and intimidation
as everything else he's not afraid of
that instead he's afraid that the people
might realize
that their government is controlled by a
bunch of billionaires
and start demanding that russia be more
transparent
[Music]
some accountability for these rich dudes
and the leaders that support them
like i said if that happens these
billionaires might be able to slip into
the shadows and
run away to some other country but putin
will be the public face
of the person who's kept this
arrangement together he will be enemy
number one his fault will be the
greatest
that is why he's afraid in a sense he's
painted himself into a corner and he's
past the point of no return
he must maintain the current system or
he will face the wrath of his people
so far the only person who has actually
garnered that wrath is alexey navalny
how corrupt
do you think is mr vladimir putin he's
the
basement of this corruption he's
personally involved in corruption
and he's encouraging our official for
corruption
it's his way of ruling country vladimir
putin made his first visit since russia
annexed crimea vladimir putin
casts his shadow across the boundary of
europe and russia
so putin goes to greater and greater
lengths to ensure that he remains
popular among his people and
show the billionaires that he's still
the right guy to keep this system of
corruption going
he does this in a few ways the first way
he keeps popularity among his people is
my favorite and it
looks like this
[Music]
he stages these absurd photo ops where
he's like surveying the land on a horse
with no shirt or
playing hockey with a bunch of literal
professional
hockey players from russia and he's
actually better than all of them and he
scores eight goals
in the course of this video it's amazing
[Music]
and people actually buy this they like
to see their leader like super powerful
and then secondly he keeps his people
happy by actually
leading the country in ways people like
his approval rating remains
quite high but more and more as
putin and this house of cards feels
threatened putin is resorting to more
extreme means to keep this system secure
okay so we got the back story on
russia and alexis navalny let's get back
to
berlin to the hospital to the icu where
lexi navalny is in a coma
he finally comes out of this coma and by
then the world has looked into the
details
of him being poisoned on this airplane
and it becomes clear
that this is the work of russian
government agents
who snuck into his hotel and laced his
underwear
with this lethal nerve poison
alexia navalny is the master of
trolling and pranking and he immediately
responds to this
he downloads some basic call spoofing
software that any of us could download
and he masks his number as a number
coming from an intelligence
secure line and he calls an intelligence
agent
who is has covet and is like ditched out
in his house at seven in the morning
he's like delirious
and he goes on to pretend that he is a
leader in the intelligence agency he has
all this insider information
and he teases out a confession from this
intelligence agent that
indeed they were the ones behind this
poisoning
i'm not going to play a bunch of that
phone call here but i'm going to put a
link in the description and you need to
go listen to it because it is
insane to listen to so what's navalny's
next move
he's in berlin he almost got killed he's
now having to learn to walk
again because the nerve poison like
really effed him up
what does he do he decides to do exactly
what he's always done
instead of cower and stay abroad he
decides to return
to russia to face putin head on upon his
return he releases a documentary that is
his most
epic documentary yet he was working on
it before he got poisoned this one
focuses
entirely on putin and his network of
bribes cronyism and loads of amazing
drone footage of
putin's lavish palace on the black sea
in true navalny fashion he makes it
clear that he's going to release the
film
after he returns to moscow because in
his words
the documentary becomes one of the most
instantly viral videos
ever to appear on the youtube platform
it currently has 110
million views my favorite part of this
dock is when navalny's team goes to the
shores of the black sea
they blow up this inflatable boat and
then they get a drone
in the air and they fly over this giant
palace on the shores of the black sea
and then
they do what i love which is animation
on top of drone footage
to help expose a crazy story they start
to pick apart
every aspect of this palace they get the
original blueprints to show that there's
a hockey rink in the basement
there's a full casino and all of this
for the benefit of the president
of the country but of course it's not
owned by the president it's owned by his
buddies
some rich billionaire dude actually owns
it but
who actually benefits from it putin it's
like a symbol of the whole russian
system
in one drone shot it's freaking
beautiful no political leader
should have a palace like this alexei
navalny who returned to moscow for the
first time since he was
poisoned last summer navalny lands in
moscow
and what happens he's immediately
arrested
on what charges well they claimed that
he was violating parole from some old
fake set of charges brought against him
years ago that were thrown out later
they were totally fake
and yet the russian state continued to
say that he
had to report for parole turns out he
couldn't report to parole officers
because
he was in a coma from being poisoned by
the russian government
and yet he gets arrested he'd only been
back on russian soil a few minutes
when alexey levine was told he was being
detained
a kiss goodbye for his wife julia
russia's justice system has been a sham
for a long time this isn't new
but just how blatant this is how clearly
faked all of this is to silence a threat
to the leader
that's a new low for russia and its
justice system
so navalny is arrested and put on trial
the people
take to the streets of moscow and around
the country the police meet them with
force
arresting over a thousand protesters and
now arresting journalists
here's a clip of navalny's lawyer
speaking
openly to the media in the middle of
moscow
and out of nowhere a group of policemen
come detain her
like in broad daylight while the
protesters clash with the police outside
the courthouse
navalny stands in a glass cage while a
largely politically motivated sham
trial about parole violation takes place
his wife yulia is in the courtroom in
the audience
watching this all happen they're making
eye contact
and in the end the system does what it's
supposed to do
navalny gets two years and eight months
of prison time
the house of cards stays stable for at
least
a little longer
this movement was never about alexis
navalny
or his politics and it likely never will
be he will never be the
leader of russia his role in all of this
is focused on one thing showing the
people how their country
really works ripping away the curtain
that
veils how their government uses the
resources of the people
and who it serves and who it doesn't
doing so
threatens the security of vladimir putin
and his friends
which is why the system is reacting
going to greater and greater lengths
to muzzle navalny and anyone like him
the question for me is how far will this
go
how much is too much before the russian
people decide
to take back their country
[Music]
thank you for watching this video it is
unfolding right now and by the time
you're watching this there may be
new information about this i'm putting a
bunch of links in the description
for some of the videos that i mentioned
that you should go watch if you want to
learn more i now want to thank today's
sponsor which is a thing i have used
forever
which is audible audible is a place that
used to just be audiobooks and that's
why i got into it like literally 10
years ago now
it is a place that has audiobooks but
also tons of other
audio spoken word just content
what i love about audible is that you
can sign up for the subscription and
then basically you can pick out one
audio book
no matter how much it costs you get it
for your subscription fee every month
and you get access to a bunch of other
unlimited content
podcasts audiobooks all sorts of really
amazing
stuff all on the app i really love
audible because it gets me learning
so much i will often listen to an audio
book while i'm working on a story
so that i can get up to speed on the
background of that story and
become just more informed about the
topics that i'm covering the audiobook
i'm listening to right now
well i'm listening to a bunch actually
but the one i'm
really loving is called fluent forever
it is the psychology of language
learning i just did a language learning
class on bright trip
and i'm like deep in the science of
language learning it's an amazing listen
i'm learning a ton uh i also have loads
of
italian language audiobooks that i'm
listening to like i'm listening to
hunger games in italian right now
it's really nice learning a bunch anyway
because you are watching this before
presidents day here in the united states
you are going to get in on one of the
biggest sales of the year that audible
does
you can get a subscription to audible
for 9.95
a month for your first six months that
is insanely cheap you pay less than 10
a month and you get any audiobook in the
entire collection
for that subscription fee plus access to
all this unlimited audio content
is a crazy good deal and it is a
no-brainer for me so go to audible.com
johnny harris or text johnny harris to
the phone number 500
500 if that's easier for you and you can
get in
on this deal clicking that link in my
description helps support this channel
but it also gets you in on this
killer deal that you don't want to miss
so thank you all for being here
thank you all for watching more videos
to come i'll see in the next one
[Music]
you